who are the top five mills of all time
sofia vergara is number one beyond that
it's going to be a little bit like of a
blend i don't want to put them in exact
order
this episode of ati with young gravy is
brought to you by whistle pig stick
around to the end for more details hey
baby
stop laughing i'm talking
hey baby it's young gravy i'm gonna
answer the internet you have to choose
three animals to start a zoo
who are you choosing
i want an albatross
stop laughing bro i'm doing a thing
i want to albatross
uh
platypus
and
so just like uh what's what's the the
the the japanese dog um
shibuya shibuya
the the doge
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah a doge albatross
and whatever else i said
perfect what movie most recently made
you cry well i watched schindler's list
last night and i cried like [ __ ] five
times so yeah
i was i was on my
are you out of your [ __ ] mind i was
next to this dude too this dude that was
called totally zanned out he was waking
up and he was like bro what are you
watching
no cap i was just oh i've seen a few
times but i was like i love that movie
it's a beautiful movie anyone else but
jesus who hasn't seen shimmers let's go
watch it but watch it alone it is very
emotional i was just like i was
literally like shedding tears it was
zanned out dude it's like yo what's up
man like what's good i'm just like man
stumble airplanes dude you cry more yeah
you do you do you do you do but there
was a snail following you for the rest
of your life and if you you touched it
you'd die how long could you survive
does it have about tour schedule it can
it can yeah it can look on instagram it
can find it can you know but it's a it's
a [ __ ] snail bro it's it's a little
it's it's a
arachnopod what do you call it uh uh i
think it's an arachna it's not a ragna
pod it's something like that though
it's a it's a cephalopod or whatever you
call that and um
you know basically i have a show in
michigan in three days
it's already on its way to new york
right now right so so actually you know
what you know what it would probably
plan ahead and it would know it was like
oh and like in like three months he has
a show in nashville tennessee and i'm
like
yeah so i i i could survive i could
survive i could survive can i just like
surround my bed with salt can i have
like a little salt circle everywhere
yeah yeah i'm going to step on it once
it's gone yeah no no
it's actually touches in your deck oh
okay
okay but if i have a gun shoot it like
10 times
all right all right you know they have
them little salt guns too i got a salt
gun we're perfect we're set i didn't got
to break no wash if you were born with
action figure hands
stuck in the same position forever what
position would your hands be in
[Laughter]
my go-to actually you know maybe one
will be just the pinky
because me me and baby no money have
always tried to find like you know like
our official you know sort of symbol the
pinky up
has been the thing but also shocker is
also our thing so you know
you know something like that
crumbled above you got larry burn
pinkies like me you got a crooked ass
one dude i know that broke but i broke
them both so yeah they're both they're
both facing inward
i break a lot of bones
oh yeah i broken about 13.
why
because i
have bad luck and i've and you're dying
so so so i'm six seven and i think that
my brain is about six four so i haven't
i have an extra three inches that aren't
really accounted for and i'm a little
bit clumsy i'm coordinated i can play
sports but but like when it comes down
to like little things i break my i'll
hurt myself
i'll say i'm just dumb in order for you
to live you have to kill a blind child
wow
you know
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blind child who has the greatest
voice of our generation are you killing
the kid
i'll kill myself [ __ ] it wow yeah let
him go
i don't think i've ever i don't know if
you've ever heard that yeah people are
always really excited
i've had a good start i love my life so
far [ __ ] kill me right now how does
that go
i really enjoyed it so far if every time
you got a boner the same song would
start playing what song would you want i
want like uh
frank sinatra uh the way you look
tonight oh yeah fancy yeah yeah so then
it's like it's already horny yeah
yeah just the way you look
tonight
every time that i get a boner it's like
damn everyone's ready you know
preparation
all right all right dale the way you
look tonight by frank sinatra who are
the top five mills of all time sofia
vergara is number one beyond that it's
going to be a little bit like of a blend
i don't want to put them in exact order
at least ann's up there kendra
yeah yes she's not okay okay okay
no no no no no no you know what we're
gonna keep it we're gonna keep with
people who have kids all right let's
grab we'll scratch her brandy love does
have a kid i've met them so she counts
so that's two does kendra lost have a
kid anyone know by the way kendra lust
has one child i'll put her on the board
jennifer anderson
she have a kid no no [ __ ] dude so fear
of regards number one number two would
be sharon nicole number three kendra
lust
sharon nicole is at us and ray's mom
just just for anyone who didn't know
yeah yeah
yeah
i'm gonna put heidi emilio up there as
well she's bad
but me and mark are boys so it's all
good mark emilia shout out to you bro
i'm gonna see you next week
and then number five
um
goodness man jane fonda
james a great answer wow
jane fonda that's it
there we go there we go that was
impressive you get to play one song at
the biggest frat party of all time
what song you playing does that have to
be my song
it's up to you bro
would it be yourself would you play your
own i mean i mean okay so so i wasn't in
a frat but i've been to plenty you know
i performed at plenty i know i know how
these frat [ __ ]
you know how they act i know what
they're into
if i had to pick one song
it's piano man
we all know anyone in a frat knows
that's the anthem so if i had to pick
one it's on the play it's piano man if i
had to pick one of my songs
i think probably oops is what would
resonate the most with them
um
i mean i think right now
well i mean betty yeah right yeah betty
but you know come on let's keep it you
know let's keep it spicy you know what
i'm saying oops or maybe betty
uh piano man
and man i don't want to be that guy but
i think that a lot of y'all frat guys
like mo bamba still yeah
that's gonna work
forever what's going on
like the viral clipboard i don't know if
you kissed the girl
and then like she goes right around and
kisses her i don't know it was me i fed
her some licorice
and she kissed you she kissed her her
whatever it was at the time yeah that
was in denmark
yeah yeah yeah yeah that girl still hits
me up to this day
that that was it that was in copenhagen
but she she was an exchange student um
from america so yeah she's out here
somewhere
she's like that snail
she's coming after me she's coming at
you
who is the one person in the world
you would least want to bang your
significant other
hmm
there's never really been a fear of mine
i heard i think about a little bit uh
that must be nice
i think probably chris hemsworth because
he's like a little bit sexier version of
me yeah so chris hemsworth
these days yeah
yeah
a lot sexy version of me and it's way
smaller too so chris hemsworth is my
answer sometimes after a long week or
you know it's tuesday right now so a
long day you like to relax with a
cocktail right now i'm on i'm on
old-fashioned maple old fashions okay
right
and i make mine with whistle pig yeah
i've got the 100 rye whiskey we got the
maple syrup you do
you doing both like that you do some
more steps to it too but this is the way
you end your tuesday
100 percent six-year aged rye whiskey
how do you give a hundred percent go to
whistlepig whiskey.com right now or
local retailer and get yourself some who
wins in a fight clint eastwood or danny
david
danny devito or clint eastwood this is a
serious question clint's been around the
block bro i mean i've seen like you've
seen unforgiven i mean it's not a cat
you know he he does something he's real
clint eastwood i think i think he's
[ __ ] on danny devito
teambagging him at the end
see i've seen a lot of clint eastwood i
haven't seen a lot of danny devito you
see i've seen a lot of cleaning for
movies i haven't seen a lot of danny
devito anything uh i just know he's that
that he's little and i met him one time
and he was he was like a little
maybe i want it maybe i want him to win
now you know
old ass clint clinton want like 80
something all right i'll go danny devito
you know
you know we just gotta give him a little
training he got it yeah
oh yeah
thank you for watching ansi internet
make sure you subscribe to the channel
comment below what guests you'd like to
see and hit the bell icon so you can get
a notification
when new episodes come out